- Accountability, my friends.
You put accountability on a
pedestal, your life will change.
Do you know how liberating it is
when you realize everything's your fault?
It gets real fucking good out here.
(hip hop music)
Anything happens at VaynerMedia
that's broken, my fault.
You know why?
I hired the person!
Like yeah, I get it
that Sally's a dickface.
Guess what?
I hired her.
I'm obsessed with practicality.
Everything I talk about feels so real,
it just might take 11 years.
And a lot of people don't have 11 years.
They don't have 11 years
because they're not willing
to put in the work to be happy
for the rest of their life.
They'd rather complain.
They'd rather blame somebody else.
Team, it was my teammate's fault.
School, fuck the teacher, right?
(audience laughs)
Work, my boss is a fuckin' idiot.
I have never lost and blamed
anything else but myself.
I love accountability.
I'm disrespectful to entitlement
and I put accountability on a pedestal.
We wanna blame everybody
but our fuckin' selves.
We have zero fuckin' accountability.
You have subconscious bias, deal with it.
Period.
When you actually realize
everything's your fault,
it gets really good out here.
Because when ya think your
boss's boss controls your shit,
when you think somebody down the street
in a building controls your shit,
then you get real sad
'cause you feel helpless.
When you realize you control
your shit, things fucking go.
When I say everything's my fault,
it doesn't mean that that's true,
it means that it's just a
happy place to think about.
It feels empowering.
People get mad at me, they're like,
Gary, what about, what about,
I'm like, you're right!
You know how many of
those things happen to me?
There's a million outside forces.
But you know, it's really exciting
to be able to think about,
like I could possibly
do something about this,
while to your point
earlier, still recognizing
whether it's grieving or
being disappointed about it,
you have to be able to do that.
But it's just, to me it's
like what's the alternative?
(ding)
- I think accountability
is very important.
- Oh man, I'm a big fan.
- You know?
- Everything on you,
everything's your fault.
You wanna really win in life,
you wanna get real happy?
You know why I'm really happy?
'Cause I think everything's my fault.
If I don't like it, I can change.
Everything wrong at VaynerMedia,
anything that ever happens,
any piece of content, anything
that ever happens in my life
100 fuckin' percent is my fault.
(audience cheers)
And let me tell you what
happens with accountability.
You get real happy.
When you feel that there's no other source
controlling your shit, all
of a sudden it gets happier.
If you complain
in the first hour I meet
you, you're finished.
- [Woman] Mmhmm.
Yeah.
- I think complaining is the tell.
And if you ask me right now
what's goin' on with my content,
there's a really interesting vibe going on
'cause it must be the
cadence of our content.
I am getting so much content
from people that are happy,
out of depression right now,
and I cannot tell you how many of them
are completely predicated on the fact
that they don't make excuses anymore
and they've taken 100% accountability.
I genuinely think it's
the unlock of happiness.
When you think it's all your fault,
what you realize is
that nobody's in control
and all of the sudden you get happy.
I just don't know how to complain.
I always think somebody has it worse.
And if somebody has it
worse, you need to shut up.
Whoever is the 7.7, if
that's the number we're at,
whoever's in last place,
whoever that person is,
if there was a world chart ranking
and Sally was dead last, she can talk.
(audience laughs)
(hip hop music)